je vous faire une petite interview
kaunas d'accord à avant d'accueillir
camille combal et bien sûr de faire le
défi avec denis bredin
il faut que je me transforme encore en
collage vous transforme en colère allez
juste que je prenne une quoi une place
de kaunas voilà une passe de colas peut
être cotée doit donc attention vous me
dites vous êtes près de ses mots avant
de commencer cette interview je voulais
vous dire que c'était très content de
vous recevoir dans l'émission je sais
merci du sort demain qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de dire aux gens pour leur
donner envie d'aller le voir ce qu on
fait juste déplacer les deux personnes
qui sont dans le public parce que je
sens qu'il me regarde avec envie et ça
me dérange c'est fait
deux personnes là on va on va s'en
occuper vous inquiétez pas mokhtar
pourrait vous demander quoi la question
vous pouvez dire aux gens pour qu'ils
ont envie d'aller voir votre film
je préfère qu'on parle de biopic qu'on
peut leur donner envie basse et moi ils
m'ont physique parfait sur écran géant
famille a vu le film non parce qu'en
fait ma famille elle est à l'étranger
enfin à limoges du conte se voit pas
beaucoup la [ __ ] est célibataire
c'est quoi votre truc d'hommes du mois
bah ouais je suis chez nous ras de terre
les âmes et cyril morale l'animateur de
l'énergie ans c'est un peu chiant peu
chiant c'est un peu long je tenais pour
combien de temps au petit de bière je
vais je vais courte et jetables a alors
la codah ces célibataires c'est quoi
votre type d'homme physiquement way et
ben en fait depuis tout à l'heure je
regarde monsieur monsieur oui d'accord
avec gilles verdez gilles verdez et
j'aime bien quoi c'est vrai moi j'aime
bien venir gilles verdez ben ouais je
prendrais ci fait je pense c'est
exactement mon style peut-être juste
avec les yeux noirs les cheveux noirs
ah ouais les abdos et peu de poil
une colossale a forcément des cop une
[ __ ] non je préfère qu'on les
appelle des faire valoir
enora si tu veux on va se voir en
version
alors et enfin il ya denis brogniart qui
est avec nous ce soir prix ça donnait ça
vous ferait plaisir que je participe à
koh lanta vous connaissez koh lanta
c'est les gens du nord qui vont à miami
avec les stars mais que les moustiques
d'or ça lol c'est ça c'est ça exactement
ça vous dirait le partitionnement note
romera du tout non gaby oh gaby
toutefois les voir son fils ça toi donc
demain et vallons et vous savez vous
avez un chien dans le film ouais et ben
à votre avis et chiens depuis le chien
du celi chien de quelqu'un autour de la
table c'est pas vrai c'est holly oh les
gars c'est au lit c'est au lit dit pas
mais la perla aussi holly wells et le
choc quelques quintaux de la table c'est
à dire sans excès
c'est le chantier c'est le chien de la
dèche non c'est le chien des nos races
et sanctionne la mère de ma mère en fait
sur l'a6 c'est pas vrai la séance avec
ma maman et c'est le chien et ouais il a
été pistonné mais votre maman était allé
assez c'est dingue non sa maman n'est
pas le chien c'est lui
à la barre
rendez vous
ça n'a rien à voir avec sa cabine quotas
sont une sorte de main et on va fixer
très bien françois ouais moi je les ai
vus je trouve ça extrêmement drôle c'est
plus qu'une performance un challenge que
de la caméra cachée elle a réussi à
faire un scénario c'est louise langues
et noémie bravo caby cottin c'est vrai
que c'est très réussi kaunas princesse
des coeurs